No one
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Continuing in alwaj where we left off a
couple of weeks back in our last session
together
in
we had stopped
at the chapter regarding the various
types of neessa, the various types of
what we would say and translate from
here on forward as filth. That which is
considered and deemed to be filthy,
neged
four things so far along with the
author.
does anybody remember the first four
that we've mentioned so far?
Human. Okay. Okay. Human feces
and urine. Human urine and feces. Okay.
And
[Arabic recitation]
we've mentioned five things. Correct.
You're right.
that which is impermissible to eat. That
which it's it's
it's meat is impermissible to eat.
So whatever comes from that animal
whether it is urine or feces or blood or
saliva or what have you any of these
things from an animal that is
impermissible to eat is haram to eat
essentially it is considered to be
nudes. So when we say an animal that is
impermissible to eat for instance a
bear or a tiger or a lion or a cheetah
or something that is impermissible to
eat. It is also considered to be neg.
And we mentioned three and four. They
rhyme. They sound the same.
[Arabic recitation]
what comes out
before
a person
before ejaculation. So it is referred
to as pre-jaculate
right and it comes out upon arousal.
It is clear. It is considered to be
clear and gooey in substance usually and
it comes with arousal and we mentioned
eli which comes after urinating right
and it's and it's described by the
scholars as being cloudy right and it
comes after urination
the sixth thing
is
the blood of menration. So menstrual
blood and we mentioned a principle
actually a number of times and that
is that
postpartum so after giving child
birth and menration
have the exact same rulings. They are
parallel in all things except for three
instances in all of Islamic in all of
Islamic law.
And so when the author tells us
menstrual blood,
what goes with that also is what?
Postpartum blood. So menstrual blood,
postpartum blood, both of these are
considered to be a type of neessa. The
author then cites the evidence for this.
He says,
"So this is sister.
This is
sister.
[Silence]
for
foreignch.
[Silence]
foreign
the daughter of Abu Bakr. So this is
sister.
She narrates and this narration by the
way is in collected by both Bkari and
Muslim. She narrates that a woman came
to the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
meaning to ask him a question. She said
if a woman
if some period or menstrual blood
comes in contact with a woman's
clothing,
how is she to deal with this? Now the
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam we we use
this as an evidence that this is a type
of filth a type of nas. Why? because he
commanded that it be that it be removed
that it be cleaned. If it was not a type
of nazza, he would say it is not, you
know, it's not necessary to remove it
upon praying. But here clearly the
context is that she's asking about the
ruling of menstrual blood with respect
to salv right will it affect a woman's
prayer now remember during these
times they didn't have these fancy
things that that women have to today
right pads and tampons and all
of these things that are used to protect
the garments and to protect a
woman's clothing from this menstrual
blood, right? Oftent times they would
use rags or they would use leaves and
they had their methods, right? But
ultimately at some point this blood
will come in contact with their
clothing. And many of the people didn't
have many various things to wear. They
had one or two dresses at most. This is
all they had. Right? So how would they
deal with this? So the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam said she is to
scrub it. Okay? She is to scrub it.
Either scrub it with itself or scrub it
with a brush or something else. Then she
is to rinse it out, ring it out, right?
Then she is to rinse it again with
water. And then she is to pray.
So if we know anything about blood, any
human blood generally, but specifically
menstrual blood is very thick. It's very
hard to get out of clothing entirely.
Most likely there will be a stain there.
This stain after this process that the
prophet mentions
is not a condition that it be removed.
the stain. If she does this, which is to
wash it, scrub it, ring it out, and then
sprinkle water on it again, whatever
remains after that process,
whether you can still see an outline or
there is still a a vague stain there
or what have you, it will not affect her
prayer. This is as far as the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam commanded. Now in
the time of ma with with the
because of their arrogance and ignorance
and their transgression
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala made things
very difficult for them at that time. So
for them when they would have a stain
this they had to remove this stain
and most usually they removed it by
cutting it physically out of the
clothing right but Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala alleviated that with our
legislation alhamdulillah right
tells us he has not placed any you
know any unnecessary undue burden
upon us in our religion. So whatever is
beyond that process is not going to
affect a woman's prayer. The prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam said she is to
scrub it and then ring it out and then
put water on it and then pray in that
clothing. Meaning why did he add that
additional
then she is to pray in it because a
person may think well it's ruined now
especially if it has a stain but the
prophet sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam
said no pray in it now it is considered
to be clean may it be clean perhaps not
you couldn't sell something that
you wouldn't buy something that has a
stain that but legislatively
it is considered
Subhanahu
[Silence]
which